So we see now how to transform a couple of different equations to this new form,
which is really helpful for us in certain ways. But there are a lot of different
equations for parabolas that don't look just like these two. In particular, what
if our equation doesn't have a leading coefficient of 1? Leading coefficient
here, refers to the coefficient in front of the x squared term, the term with
the highest power. In both of these situations, that coefficient is 1, which we
know makes factoring a lot simpler, and presumably, also changes how we complete
the square. In fact, recall the equation that we came up with as our final
equation, for calculating Grant's profit based on the price that he charges per
glasses wiper set. Last lesson we had p equals negative 200 c squared, plus
18,400c, minus 133,200, here our leading coefficient is negative 200, that's
certainly not equal to 1. If we want to find out exactly where the vertex of
this equation is, we're going to need to get this in that new form, using
completing the square. Well, we'll get to solving this eventually, but for now
I'd like us to start out with a equation similar to this, and that its leading
coefficient is not 1, and over through that, to eventually be able to deal with
the Grant situation. Here I've graphed the equations y equals x squared, that
parent parabola we've seen so many times, and then a second parabola y equals
three x squared, this green one right here. So judging from the relationship
between these two graphs, how does multiplying the leading coefficient of a
parabola change the shape of the parabola? Does it shift it vertically, shift it
horizontally, make it wider, or make it more narrow?